okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the motor effect and Fleming's
left hand rule basically all this is is
it shows us the direction that a force
act if we have an interaction between
two magnetic fields one magnetic field
caused by two magnets and one magnetic
field caused by concentric circles
around a wire carrying current so it's
kind of easier just to start explaining
it so let's say here I have two magnets
so here is the North Pole of one and the
South Pole is the other so as always a
magnetic field we have the the field
lines running from north to south like
this okay
so in order to get some motion to get a
force being a resulting force being
produced we also need another magnetic
field so currently we just have one but
if we had a magnetic field created
around a wire then we could create a
force now what this dots here is showing
is it showing that we have a wire going
at 90 degrees to the magnet of these
magnets so it's coming up out of the
page like shown with this pen here so
depending on which way the current is
flowing depends on the kind of the
direction of that magnetic field now
Fleming's left hand rule is really
clever because it allows us to figure
out which way a force is going to be
created is a force going to be created
in that direction or that direction by
creating a force we could create a motor
so we could create a kind of we can
create movement which could be used for
things like in a washing machine or the
wheels of an electric car or anything
that has a kind of turning motion so by
doing these interaction between two
magnetic fields we can create a force
now there's three different fingers
involved in Fleming's left hand rule
Fleming's left hand rule your hand looks
like this now each diff
finger represents a different thing your
thumb represents motion so that is going
to be the direction that the force is
going in okay your first finger your
first finger shows you the direction of
the field lines so that's the direction
of the magnetic field and your second
finger your second finger shows the
direction of the current so let's have a
quick think how this applies how this
relates to this diagram here so as we
can see the field lines first finger
field lines the first finger is going
from north to south let's imagine the
current was coming the current was
coming directly out of the page towards
the the camera so the current is coming
out of this wire towards the camera okay
so my first finger I'm going to show
that way my current I'm going to show
coming out of the page so as a result I
can see that my thumb motion is pointing
that way so if the current is coming up
out of the page the force is going to be
in that direction field line current
because of the position of my hand in
Fleming's left hand rule the force would
be that way so let's have a faint if the
force if the current was flowing the
other way so we're going to keep the
field lines in the same direction
going from north to south but this time
we're imagining the current is flowing
down this wire demonstrate by this pen
into the page so let's see how that
changes things
so my field lines is still going that
way from north to south
my current this time is going down into
the page so therefore my motion my force
must be in this direction this time
so that's how Fleming's left hand rule
works all you've got to do is make sure
you keep your hand in that position your
thumb shows direction the motion the
force the F your first finger shows the
directions the field lines always from
north to south and C shows your second
finger shows the direction of the
current whether it's flowing down into
the page or up out of the page and by
using this rule you could figure out the
direction of the force you can also if
you didn't know the directions of field
lines as long as you've got the other
two you can always figure out the third
one as long as you keep your hands in
this position thank you very much